now let me bring you some breaking news
sky news understands that a man who held
a rabbi and members of his congregation
hostage at a synagogue in texas
yesterday was british all four captives
were released but we know that the
hostage taker himself is now dead let's
get more on this guys intima rasheed
joins us so injury what more have we
been learning
well we can tell you now officially from
the foreign office here in the uk they
have released a statement saying that we
are aware of the death of a british man
in texas
and are in contact with the local
authorities it's also understood that
the foreign office haven't yet been
approached
for direct assistance by the us
authorities but we can confirm that the
gunman who held a rabbi and three other
hostages at a synagogue in texas was in
fact a british
national now this was about an 11 to 12
hour hostage situation in collyville in
texas um where the gunman had hold of
these hostages inside this place of
worship it ended in the early hours of
uh this morning where elite fbi team and
swat squads uh have to storm the
synagogue and subsequently rescue the
hostages one was released in the middle
of negotiations and then three were
rescued by the u.s authorities and
subsequently the suspect
died now part of uh the hostages
situation when he was inside the
synagogue was actually captured on a
live stream on facebook and on zoom it
was just audio so we couldn't actually
see what was going on inside the
synagogue at the time but the audio
recorded that a man
which we now believe to be this british
man that the gunman at the time
was shouting quite angrily and you could
hear he was speaking
in that british
accent um there is still no motivation
about exactly
why this has happened but we can hear
from the fbi as they spoke outside the
synagogue after the incident
today's result which was for safe
hostages and situation resolved was
really uh was really a result of
a whole long long day of hard work by
nearly
200 law enforcement officers i'm also
extremely proud of the team of
negotiators fbi agents and local police
officers
who worked all day long engaging this
subject and likely saved the lives of
the subjects just through their
engagement it's very likely this
situation would have ended very badly
early on in the day had we not had
professional consistent negotiation with
the subject
there's a quite a large police operation
that took place to reprimand this
hostage taker this gunman as we now know
a british national and as i mentioned
some of uh what was happening inside the
synagogue was actually recorded
on zoom and streamed live on facebook
that's because of the sermon that was
taking place in the synagogue at the
time that subsequently has been taken
down and just a bit about the motive i
said earlier that there is still no
confirmation of the motive but u.s
investigators actually believe that the
hostage taker was seeking the release of
afia siddiqui now she was a pakistani
doctor known as lady al-qaeda she's been
sentenced to 86 years for the attempted
murder of u.s soldiers and is currently
in prison in the united states now
police confirmed that dialogue is taking
place between the u.s authorities tel
aviv and london as well and those
dialogues with london will no doubt
continue now we know that this is a
british national but there will be
questions undoubtedly about how a man
traveled from the uk entered at the
united states managed to get hold of a
gun and managed to take hold of hostages
inside a place of worship
indeed thank you for updating us nz